creativity I many people that come to
work with me know nothing about the
brain they come to me to learn about the
brain they bring their own ideas and
their own techniques so they may come
with a background immunology they may
come a background in molecular biology
or yeast genetics or in Mouse genetics
and we combine the postdoctoral fellow
skills and mind in order to tackle
problem and we both enjoy and it's
essential to select a problem that is
gratifying not only for you but for the
person that you're working with because
otherwise they don't feel this is their
problem and they're motivated to do it
and what about for younger students or
do you tend to concentrate on they only
take one graduate student at a time and
even with graduate students that try to
sense out I've been very gifted been
very fortunate and the quality of
graduate students I've had many of them
have had wonderful ideas where we talked
together I would suggest something I
tell them for us to just walk around the
lab and to speak to people and see what
projects really interest them at one
point I would make is I encourage
students to tackle important problems
because I think once you've sensed what
it's like to really solve something
wonderful you become addicted the
satisfaction of doing something which is
novel and which is important this is
very very satisfying so how is a young
person do you spot an important problem
because it presumably yes it with them
and you help them that's how I can be
useful I can tell them this is not
interesting this is it's a question of
taste you help them develop taste